yeah welcome to a new blitz game here
playing against my way from Norway and I
played him so often okay in the
caro-kann c5 i think it was six yeah
what I recommended in my series for icc
german-language caricom repertoire yeah
I'm getting old I'm really getting old I
simply forgot what i recommend it yeah I
came between g4 let's try to to get by
with normal moves how to continue may be
here attacking the Queen I couldn't take
on c5 because g7 was hanging so some
have a problem but what is he doing now
if it takes he gives me the two bishops
and maybe I can then simply recapture ya
know I can also recapture I hope don't
see it raw egg
yeah the night is a bit offside on age
six but maybe it can go to f5
yeah i played this guy very often he
doesn't know anything special in the
opening but he's really good in an
impractical play Justin I tactical
positions are but you need to calculate
properly he's really good ok so maybe
simply castling @ f 6m this somehow look
sir this looks ok against the Queen I
mean shouldn't be bad too to activate in
this of this fashion
if you take them I'm not quite sure
maybe even look takes that sort of
rocked heads looks a bit strange maybe
because it puts yourself into Bishop g5
but it also wins the tempo on the Queen
maybe I can even known get some attack
on the F how rock g 60 could also be
possible
gaap Bishop g5 this is the question how
to learn how to deal with this
yeah simple movers San night to f7 but
it it feels a bit passive maybe maybe I
can play even more more actively here
maybe this one
see for the Sun this I didn't didn't
think of it all really c4
I didn't expect that he's got so much
time in this position okay come on let's
go forward I mean he can't play Bishop
d3 but moving everything all over again
but it seems very slow so
gal kiti got the foursquare
okay me to get something going him
before I mean yeah it's nothing I can do
about that my idea no is any way to get
some attack on the King see five year
probably need to drop back
yeah well okay do whatever you want but
I'm trying to make you now okay let's
see
be sure before i go nite age four and
this should be something I mean he needs
to take maybe Bishop c4 word cannot
believe this anyway I've got to look on
the king the bishop denied I mean it's a
lot yeah Bishop g6 I take f3 takes and
queen age for I mean on h2 this is
dangerous
I didn't calculate I mean I'm just I'm
just playing on check on the basis that
I've got everything on the King now mmm
we made Shawn okay jack yeah not much
choice
yeah this is this is true he he controls
a five now and and allows Queen g3
hmm let's do bad
probably need to take this
is there some way to play this yeah i'm
a rope down it's not working I think it
was working but I somehow botched this
up i'm usually i'm not so bad with with
the intuition if this was good or not
and i think it was a really good attack
but it didn't work out I made some
mistake after sacrificing i'm pretty
sure curious to check this time morning
with the computer afterwards
yeah should drag sign here but where
what a shame lack resign so now let's
look how I could have one it's the same
same story now maybe I computer says
it's not working surprise which really
surprised me I think okay this looks
very dangerous 95 check and this is the
only the only defense but it is enough
young
yeah giving every foursome of course
from work I cannot believe he can make
all these four moves never developing
anything and don't caring about the king
that seems to be working at least them
don't see don't see reputation
probably just knight to e7 computer
wants to go 95 but if I need to do that
then then this is nonsense check it's
absurd surprised I mean yeah but it
seems to work out it's a bit lucky for
white that he just just about is able to
defend this he's got got no offense on
the king but it seems to be okay even if
i take here you can really just just
recapture he always has twin b3 with the
check to to get over to the King side
this is what I miss this check otherwise
I mean I played just this and it's gone
or at least after F for me I'm immune
winning here because of check this check
this kind of things but I didn't I
didn't appreciate this queen bee three
was check and then F for this was what I
would I didn't I didn't really see and
this is what what helps white keeping
keeping this together otherwise see what
would simply be lost even here I mean F
voice is not chanting the DC draw am a
descent f4 I didn't see that it looks
still looks dangerous but that's
probably just nothing okay thanks for
watching